the series celebrity Plastic Surgeons of
Beverly Hills sheds light on everything
from breast lifts to butt implants but
one emotional episode tackles every
woman's nightmare suddenly losing your
hair and that's what happened to one
woman who works for Will and Jada Smith
long and luscious short and sassy and
every color of the rainbow some are born
with it while other stars get Wiggy with
it I need somewhere to go when I don't
have to be Hollywood when I can take my
wig but what do you do when your hair
falls out well Alexis seaton face that
horror after a combination of pregnancy
hormones and years of tight weaves which
caused major hair loss so I noticed like
my hair was just constantly like falling
out falling out falling out I did not
realize that it was like like completely
bald so she met with dr. Craig ziering
who says he's helped fix the looks of a
lot of stars we're seeing a lot of
celebrity clientele a lot of musicians
artists athletes we see a lot of Realty
royalty maybe Prince William could pay
him a visit because what he does is
transplant a patient's own hair into the
area of their scalp that is balding we
were able to harvest the hair from the
back of her head and recreate a nice
natural hairline and it looks completely
natural the doc is part of a team on the
celebrity Plastic Surgeons of Beverly
Hills
shaving part of her head he then cuts a
strip of Alexis's scalp where healthy
hair is growing then divides it into two
thousand tiny grass so we do 2,000
grafts you're getting more than 5,000
hairs that are being moved the procedure
cost somewhere between 10 to 20,000
dollars and takes just one day Alexis's
hair line is now filling in with her own
hair and while she may not have her own
wind machine to make her hair flow like
Beyonce's she's pretty happy with the
results I have my life back as a woman
your hair is everything